hey everyone Spencer here and today
we're looking at Ghost Recon wildlands
but feel free to leave a comment below
as to what you'd like us to see us do
next if you enjoyed this video feel free
to share like and subscribe and stay
tuned for more let's get into it the
agent a murdered you knew him he was a
friend of mine sorry for your loss
I could say it comes with the job but it
doesn't get any easier No
[Music]
guess you bent down here a while I've
been living as Karen Bowman
international aid worker for just about
five years means living rough but as a
cover
gets me out about least it comes with a
chopper how'd you get in country the flu
in business class from announced hey I'm
refreshed and ready for work right I
just hitched rides from barranco Peru
how about you I got on board a bus and
who we are Janina drank all the way to
be his own nobody wants to deal with a
drunk on the bus that explains why you
smell like gas
I heard rumors about you guys I was a
rookie field officer in Moscow when the
coup went down there was talk you were
involved it must have been someone else
we were never there it's not every day
you get to meet an urban legend in the
flesh you should tell that's my kid
maybe he'd listen when I tell him to
take the trash out is it hard being
someone who doesn't officially exist you
tell me Karen Bowman international aid
worker I'm sure you've seen the horrible
[ __ ] up [ __ ] humans are capable of
when there are zero repercussions but
let me tell you right now no matter how
you compartmentalize how you desensitize
you can't prepare for golf swing you
he's got a religious street that rates
pretty close to delusional he's taken
vows of poverty chastity if he's not in
it for the church or the money he's in
it for the power this joint task force
CIA DEA JSOC I'm your resident spook for
this ride welcome to operation
Kingslayer our briefings had to be a
contention of locals mixed Terrence 26
they're a group of rebels who's been
giving Luna dad and smelted belong to
some resistance we'll meet their leader
bakatari soon as we touch down the
Libyans have a long history of hating us
Yankees but this time let's hope the
enemy of my enemy will be my friend but
don't turn your back on him I'm not
going to
four soldiers is to help you promised
that's and allow promised a single
Yankee died so you send a handful of
soldiers hundreds of will evens have
died from sent Lanka's bullets where
will my hundreds of soldiers come from
as Americans we aren't here remember
these soldiers are the best covert ops
team our country has to offer with their
help you won't need hundreds of soldiers
are you familiar with the word huber
sing at a bowmen meet packet re leader
of the resistance group guitarist 26 we
will be working with the rebels to
destabilize thathe Blancas organization
they've been fighting Santa Blanca and
corrupt bolivian officials for nearly
six years now we'll need to coordinate
targets there is no time for this we
have information on a Madam's
whereabouts Amaru
you found him Amara's one of the
founders of the Qataris 26 more than
that her group is founded on his ideas
without his theories of an agrarian
proletariat there will be no organized
resistance against Santa Blanc and the
corruption in our government Amaro must
be saved if you were to assist my people
it would do much to earn my confidence
where is he we do not know exactly we
know he's in this province and that
there is a scent of like a lieutenant
who knows where he is
I'll put a call in to the activity see
if they can dig more Intel out of the
airwaves start looking for that
lieutenant and keep me informed of
everything via SAP phone good hunting
shaving a motto is important to our cars
Yankee make sure you don't kill the
Santa Blanca lieutenant before you get
the chance to ask him questions
[Music]
time to earn your pay people put on your
game faces I tell you I'm not too
comfortable working with packet are in
these rebels their kind of ideology
always ends up with more bodies in the
ground what's your feeling on this OP
end of the day this is a revenge mission
we need to focus and get this done quick
before we get stuck between local
politics and the firestorm of cartel
bullets first objective tracked down
that Santa Blanca lieutenants who can
find a modern yeah
myself we got hostiles in the area don't
want to spook the target switch to
suppressors
good eyes in the target let's move
[Music]
Drona's airborne - spotted one with
submachine guns
moving to position hey women s then say
the word
hostile down
ready to fire
say the word boss
should be okayed it will let the rebels
know where to find me supplies it could
pay us back later
we got a Sicario by the West our tango
down
I just talk the talk and spin the tools
I make your asses bounce this mixture
that's a kill
go pair a total Sabra Vienna beach come
on here's the deal [ __ ] you answer my
questions where I put a bullet in your
gut leave you to die in your own [ __ ]
go and see end this road what do you
want Amaru
where can I find him you serious that's
what this is about
sure thing he said I know your farm go
on and you can see what we do to people
who [ __ ] with us people like you
we need to get this done in the hurry
tomorrow's an old man he's not gonna
last long under torture [ __ ] they've
been working on a for a while there's a
good chance he's already dead maybe
maybe not
Palmer is a major player in the rebel
movement the cartel will keep them alive
as long as they can to find out what it
is we can't afford to take any chances
there's too much riding on this let's
move
[Music]
let's get moving cartel isn't gonna wait
around for us to track down and rescue
Amaru
[Music]
tango monkey he's a little close to
civilians
rally up
back it up they're gonna see fire fire
fire
clear on this side